You told me he was out for the season
We broke his collarbone and sacked the
State Farm Dog
No man can come back from that
This is not a man we're talking about
This is AARON...RODGERS
Didn't finish the job?
God help the NFC
Mr. Rodgers, welcome back to the Elite Hotel
Your pinnie, sir
Rodgers! You're back!
How many years has it been?
Seven weeks. I'm coming for you
I'm coming for the wild card
Ah, ah, hotel rules. Can't hit a QB in a pinnie
Are you here on business, Peppers?
Afraid so, old friend
Hut, hut
[Hail Mary, it's a Hail Mary!]
[Rodgers with another Hail Mary!]
Packers have a highly improbable
route to the playoffs. Why is he doing this?!
Because he's Baba Yaga — The Boogeyman
♫ Like a good neighbor, Rodgers is- ♫
Here